[Applause]
five incredible movies
and the spirit award for best director
goes to
maggie gyllenhaal
for the last
daughter this is maggie gyllenhaal's
second win tonight she is also up for
best feature
maggie's acting credits include crazy
heart the honorable woman and of course
the dark knight
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the last time i saw chloe uh
[Laughter]
well we'll talk about it later
oh man thank you
really it means so much to me
keep it together um
as a director
i more than anything i believe in love
um
kyra stomy said
i think expressing love is as important
as feeling it i don't mean to lay down
rules but i think expressing love is
among its most beautiful manifestations
now
i had never seen a kirstami film until i
met my brilliant editor alfonzo
goncalves fonzie are you here could you
just
where are you
oh
i um
yeah nominated for akira which is a
gorgeous movie
i watched so many good films on his
recommendation where is the friend's
house ifi danzante
and those films reminded me what it
looks like and what it feels like when
somebody
is
true to themselves when they listen to
themselves what an amazing gift from an
editor
all the filmmakers and film lovers here
know how integral an editor like fawns a
sound mixer like leslie schatz a
production designer like inval weinberg
a composer like dick and hinchliff are
to the films we make
thank you
and thank you to my
she's in paris i guess she's sleeping
but my fucking astonishing dp helen
louvard we
lived in each other's dreams me and
helen and we sweat together every day
talia and osnot
ah you were
really
you were the first people to tell me
that i was a director and not a like
okay one day maybe we'll see kind of
director but you got me in touch with
the urgency
with which um i i had to do this that i
had to do it now
so thank you thank you again to netflix
i can't even believe this
for your um unending support
you
have been
artistically and logistically full of
love
to ec listen nobody ever makes their
first movie i don't know where you guys
are as a
an independent filmmaker and comes out
loving their financiers
but i do
okay
courtney elise michelle deb robert and
sarah
i'm not going to take all the time up
here to thank you you like literally
have held me up
some of you have known me for a very
very long time
you pick up my calls on the weekend
and you are a huge part of the reason
that i'm standing here right now okay
one last thing i love independent film
i
grew up making independent film i love
watching independent film
everyone here in this tent has scrambled
to get their movies made
on our set
when we ran into a problem because we
didn't have enough money or we didn't
have enough time talia and osnot and i
had a mantra and i think that everyone
in this movie could raise a glass to
that which was we would make a
compromise and we would say next time
35 millimeters and 35 days
[Laughter]
thank you so much
[Music]
you